قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه سيبذل قصار جهده لاستعاده
الامن في الحدود الشماليه لاسرائيل
واعاده الاسرائيليين الى بلداتهم هناك حسب
تعبيره واضاف خلال جوله تفقديه للواء حرام
769 على الحدود الشماليه لاسرائيل مع
لبنان انه يفضل ان يتم ذلك دون حمله
عسكريه واسعه
النطاق من هنا اوجه رساله الى حزب الله
وهو حتى الان كان يظن اننا خيوط عنكبوت
وفجاه يرى منا ردا وقوه هائله وتضامنا بين
السكان لدينا تصميم على القيام بكل ما
يلزم لاستعاده الامن في الشمال وانا اقول
لك هذه هي سياستي وسنبذل قصار جهدنا
لاستعاده الامن في الشمال والسماح
لعائلاتكم بالعوده الى ديارهم بامان لا
يمكن العبث معنا وسنفعل كل ما هو ضروري ن
بالطبع نفضل ان يتم ذلك دون حمله واسعه
النطاق لقد اعطينا حزب الله مثالا لما
يحدث لاصدقائه في الجنوب وهذا ما سيحدث
هنا في
الشمال